(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We mustn't be
victims but protagonists
of our stories.
- I heard that you stalked
Steve McQueen for this role,
basically like...
- I did not stalk him.
- I'm kidding am kidding but
you did passionately want
to get this role the minute
you heard it announced?
- Yeah I get I didn't
know specifically what
the role would be but I just
knew that he had something
to do with bringing
Caribbean culture to the BBC.
I was like I wanna be involved in that,
I don't care if I'm a tree,
I don't care if I'm the
person going to run off
to get the curry spice,
I wanna be involved.
So that was in 2015 and yeah, here we are.
- I mean, it's really incredible
both like you and John
coming to it because I
know you guys both did
the same preparatory acting program.
And now really tell these
black British stories
on such a global audience.
And it's something that's
universal over here in America.
Our stories don't get told.
So talk about what it's like to bring
a story that maybe people know about,
but they don't know in detail.
- Man, again, you'd only know about it
if you were a part of that
community and (indistinct)
at that time.
It's not on a global scale
but we're pushing it out there
right now which is so great.
It's great to be able
to have this opportunity
to be represented, your
culture being represented
within mainstream media.
Steve just being bold
and just being man enough
to stand by his word and
say this isn't his heart,
this isn't his heart 15 years ago.
And to see it through right
to the end is beautiful.
So it's a treat to come
to work and see people
that you connect with.
I had shared the same culture as you,
it's just a beautiful tree
and just proud that this
is now being broadcasted
to the world.
- What's really incredible too,
is it's not just one story,
it's several chapters and
it really gives an in-depth
sort of narration of
this particular community
throughout the time period
that they were not seen.
But in doing so, you're
playing real life people,
and that's daunting as
well as I would assume,
very invigorating but what
was it like playing homage,
the real life woman that you're portraying
and how difficult was it to balance?
- Again, that was like, you're
constantly thinking about
the script and thinking about
the words that you have to say
and the scenes that you have to do,
and constantly checking
in with Steve to be like,
are you sure I feel it
says something like this?
Because you want her to be proud,
you want her to feel like you
correctly represented her.
'Cause this story is
now taking the forefront
to be showcased.
So you carry that.
It's a little bit of
nerves when you carry that.
Is great because you're not
just having one story being told
and pushed to the forefront.
You get into several different stories
that you didn't know about.
So it's just something
fresh and something new,
for us right now in 2020
but these are stories
that were buried and hidden for years
So it's important its
important that we share it.
- [Narrator] These are
new types of human beings.
- Of the entire sort of
small acts anthology.
Yours is the only one that's based off
of like a completely fictional
story and dance and music
is just such a huge part of it.
I was just curious, was that
daunting for you guys as
the cast to know you guys got to pull off
these amazing dance numbers?
- Definitely, at first I think
it was more the fact that
it wasn't based on a true
story that we were quite like,
Oh gosh, you know.
But afterwards, when we understood it
and we understood that this
episode is an escape from
the frustrations from
watching the other films,
cause I myself haven't had
the chance to see them yet,
but I know what they are about.
And, you know I can imagine
they're very hard hitting.
So it's almost as if our episode
is a house party in itself
of being able to escape.
Yeah, I also think it's still
even though it's not based
on a true story, there
is still people's truths.
I spoke a lot to my mom and
my dad and these are that
it's still relatable it's still the truth.
And there's gonna be so
many different moments
that people go, Oh my gosh, Oh yeah.
I know my dad watching it
and something as small as
the guy is banging against
the wall in the party
and my dad was like, yes, yes, yes.
So it will still definitely relate.
- Yeah, and big ups to Steve
and the entire like production team
because the one thing I
know is I wasn't living
in the seventies but I
live for that time period.
And although it was a
huge sixties and seventies
huge point of unrest,
it also provided some of
the most incredible music
and dance and Steve lived in that.
So talk about him really
sort of immersing you guys
in this world.
And then also how it was
just working with him
'cause I know he's a director
that gets great performances
from his actors.
- Oh he is incredible, definitely,
so Owen is the early eighties
and with Steve, he's so open
and trusting of his actors
to bring what they have to the table.
We also worked with an incredible
choreographer called Carol
and her thing was she got
the supporting artists.
For example, before we started filming,
she got them in a room,
she said it's not enough
to just have them in costume.
I need to play some music,
I need them to understand
this energy that needs
to be had for this film,
they need to know it.
So I think even just
doing that, it was like,
there was no to me, there
was, we were all together.
It's not about leads or support
and everyone was just together
and as a whole in that.
And then she got us proper
on the dance in to understand
how different the dancing was back then.
And to understand that
it's heavy in your feet
and it's grounded and you're
connected to the earth.
And I think that is obviously
why Steve asked Carol
to come and step in
because he really wanted us
to understand it's not just
about just dancing to dance.
It means so much more it's
again people releasing
their frustrations, letting things out,
feeling it in their body.
It was so beautiful to be
able to experience that.
- Yeah, and like you said,
yours is the only one
that's not based off of history,
but it still hits within
the whole vibe of the
anthology over several decades.
This idea of beauty
and art in the midst of
social and political unrest.
And although yours leans
more in the entertainment
and the things that people did to escape,
all of the other stuff
is like so still there
and a part of it.
And I'm actually curious though,
since it is more centered
in, on the dance stuff,
if you have a particular
moment from a dance movie,
besides yours
(laughs loudly)
say like, 'cause I always
think to like this she's all
that dance moment.
Like that's just like a random
dance moment in a teen movie,
but I love it.
I wonder if you have one of those
that you particularly love.
- One would be the dance in Death Proof.
Have you watched Death
Proof by Quentin Tarantino?
(yells loudly)
Her(indistinct)
I love Tarantino and I love...
that dance has always stayed with me.
- [Narrator] They are leaders,
but are rooted deep among those they lead.
- Playing real people,
there's always like a legacy
and a lot of homage you have
to pay to these real life
historical figures.
But then also try to tell
a compelling stories.
So I'll start with you
and then Malachi if you can talk about
portraying these real life characters
and how you approached it.
- Well, fortunately, you
know, I went to drama college.
What does that mean?
And I say, it's a weird place
to answer these question,
but I feel it's not 'cause
I did went to drama college.
So what does that mean?
Well, we were taught a method
of being able to access
ways and means to explore
different energies
and psychological mathematics
when it comes to portraying,
whatever it is that is
portrayed in the mangrove,
in Frank specifically.
So, what do we know?
We know that this is a historical thing.
We also know that this is
not a pain that is unique.
Frank is not the first and last person
to essentially suffer abuse
as a result of the color
of his skin.
So we know that, it seems
to be an ancestral cry
or something, maybe not an ancestral cry,
but it's about that feeling is about,
so we know that daunting, yes,
because you've gotta take it
seriously, but fortunately,
we were built for that we're actors.
It's not and it's no biggie.
It is a biggie.
It having to play these
roles but fortunately,
we went to these places and
we've studied life enough
and we've studied human nature enough
to be able to, when someone's
like anger, pain, frustration,
abuse is the result of certain factors go.
Fortunately, we got a lot of that stuff
in the back pocket already, right?
All of us, you, Malachi our parents.
So that's not easy, but
that's a help useful.
And then what you have is
the idea that says, yeah,
but this is not now this is them.
And what does that mean?
It's the same shit, sorry,
you know but it is, I see it's the same...
Oh yeah it's that in it.
- Yeah, it's problems
throughout the diaspora.
And then Malachi, if you
can go ahead and talk about,
again, playing the real person too.
- Yeah, I mean for me, we
have some other characters
in the Mangrove Nine that didn't have
I guess I don't wanna use the word fame,
but Darcus Howe was
known, he had a TV show.
He was the involved politically,
he was a known face.
And so there was a lot
more documents on him.
There's a lot more videos on
him, where you can actually
see him speaking and expressing himself.
And so for that, there's one
thing playing a real person
and there's another thing
playing a real person that is
known to a community already.
And so there was a weight behind it,
even though I knew very
little about Darcus.
At first, there was a way
to kind of get this right
as there would be for every
character, to be honest,
but more so for him I guess,
because he, like I said,
my mom knows who he was, he
grew up watching him on TV.
And then you have to
remember as Shaun said
that you're an artist, so
he is a person that existed,
but so should every
character that you play,
you should approach them
in the same way of bringing
the truth and light to this person
that was previously unknown
or at least unknown in part
and telling their story.
So it was approached in the same way.
(slow upbeat music)